[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
قمه السعوديه صينيه في الرياض للدفع
بشراكه الاقتصاديه بين الجانبين الى مرحله
جديده
وسط محاولات قمع الاحتجاجات السلطات
الايرانيه تنفذ اول عقوبه اعدام ضد محتجا
لطعنه رجل امنه
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي توافق على قرار لدعم الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه
وبوتين يحذر من مخاطر اللجوء للسلاح
النووي في اوكرانيا واشنطن تتهممه بعدم
المسؤوليه
صباح الخير تحتضر الرياض اليوم قمه صينيه
سعوديه للدفع بالعلاقات الاقتصاديه
الثنائيه
الذي وصل الى العاصمه السعوديه بالامس قال
انه سيبحث مع العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان
وولي عهده الامير محمد بن سلمان التعاون
الثنائي والقضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
مؤكدا ان التعاون العملي مع السعوديه اسفر
عن نتائج مثمره في المجالات كافه مشيرا
الى وجود ثقه استراتيجيه متبادله مع
السعوديه وبشكل مستمر
[موسيقى]
ننتقل مباشره الى المركز الاعلامي للقمه
السعوديه الصينيه وزميل نايف الاحمر اليك
نايف
شكرا فاطمه صباح الخير مشاهدينا اهلا بكم
الى هذه التغطيه الخاصه والتي تنفرد بها
العربيه لمواكبتي قمم الرياض في هذه
الزياره الرسميه للرئيس الصيني سجن بيج
الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض التي ادت اتت
بعد دعوه من العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان
بن عبد العزيز اذا المشاهدين تحتضنوا
الرياضه اليوم قمه صينيه سعوديه تهدف الى
تعزيز العلاقات الاقتصاديه الثنائيه كما
من المتوقع ان يتم توقيعه عدد من
الاتفاقيه الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
ومع بدل زياره الرئيس الصيني اكد الامير
فيصل بن فرحان وزير الخارجيه السعودي ان
استضافه الرياض للقمم الثلاث تؤكد العزمه
لتعزيز العلاقات مع الصين كما اشار وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الى ان العلاقات مع
الصين استراتيجيه في ظل التطورات على ساحه
الدوليه هذا ولفه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
الى ان العلاقات الاقتصاديه مع الصين تسير
بخطوات متسارعه فيما اضاف وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الى تطلع المملكه للعمل مع الصين
والدول الخليجيه والعربيه خلال قمم الريال
كما اكد وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان التعاون بين الصين
والسعوديه ساهم في الحفاظ على استقرار سوق
النفط في العالم واضاف في تصريحاتنا
وردتها وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان المملكه
والصين تسعيني لتعزيز التعاون في سلاسل
امداد الطاقه عن طريق انشاء مركز اقليمي
في المملكه للمصانع الصينيه مشيرا كذلك
الى ان المملكه ترتبط بعلاقات متينه
وروابط استراتيجيه وثيقه مع الصين تشمل
العديد من المجالات ومن اهمها مجالات
الطاقه المختلفه اكد وزير الطاقه السعوديه
ان هناك رغبه مشتركه في الاستثمار بمجمعات
التكرير والبترول كيميائيه المتكامله في
كلا البلددين
اه ينضم الي هنا في الاستديو الكاتب
الصحفيه السعوديه جاسر الجاسر سيد جاسم
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه اذا وصل
الرئيس الصيني الى الرياض اليوم من
المرتقب ان يلتقي بالملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عهد الامير محمد بن سلمان ما
المتوقع في هذه المباحثات ان يتم النقاش
حوله في القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه
والثنائيه طبعا
صباح الخير يعني هذا يوم مهم بصراحه ويوم
جذري ليس فقط للمملكه انما
لنقل يعني صيغه تشكل العالم الجديد القائم
على التفاهمات والتعاون وادراك نقاط الجذب
المشتركه بين كل البلدان المملكه والصين
الرابط بينهما اكثر من علاقات يعني
تقليديه وعلاقتها بالمماسيه واكثر من
اتفاقات اقتصاديه ونكره روابط مني يعني
يعززها نوع من الدفه نوع من التقارب نوع
بشكل اساسي نذكر فقط في تصريح الرئيس
الصيني وفي تصريح الامير عبد بن سلمان
تكررت كلمه الثقه هذا المعيار هذه الثقه
معيار اساسي الصين وهي كانت تدخل لطارات
التنميه كانت تعتمد على النفط السعوديه
والنفط السعودي كانت الميزه الاساسيه في
الثقه ولذلك لم تتدخل خلف او ترتبك مخططات
وخطط وبرامج التنميه في الصين المعتمده
على الطاقه نتيجه هذه الثقه في توريد
الطاقه الى الصين بثبات
وكل التقلبات سواء كانت سياسيه واقتصاديه
وحتى ظرفيه معينه
وبالمقابل الان هذه العلاقه نفس العمليه
الان ليحدث هذه الثقه المملكه في اطار
الاقتصاديه بوصلتها رؤيه المملكه
ومستهدفات الحكم فيها وهذه البصله من اجل
تحقق ليست مشاريعانيه ومرحليه هي خطه اي
خطه بناء مستقبل هي عمليا
معينه في المملكه تدور هذه البوصله وتنتقد
دول الاكثر ملائمه وبالتالي يتم العمل
عليها فهذه بوصله كيف تتفق مع مع دوله مثل
الصين الصين هي في التجاره في الاقتصاد
بالنسبه للعالم اصبحت علامه بنموها
الاقتصاد السريع همم بالاقتصاد طبعا
الكبير والذي من المتوقع انه يصحاب اكبر
الاقتصادات في العالم خلالها
تجربه تنمويه في الصين
وبالتالي والخيارات الموجوده في الصين على
كافه المستويات
والمهارات العاليه ايضا هذه جوانب مغريه
وجذابه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه لكن
المعيار الاساسي احنا اللي دخلنا المعايير
الاقتصاديه البحته نضيف عليها حزمه
الثقافه حزمه الثقه وعزز لانه هذه التنميه
تحتاج الى ثقه لا تحتاج الى انقطاعات لا
يمكن للمملكه تنفذ مشاريع المستقبليه في
ظل يعني او وفق همم مخططات قد ترتبك
سياسيا بسبب مواقف سياسيا لكن بالتالت عزز
هذا التعزيز القائم بين الجانبين يضمن
الارتياح للطرفين في مسارات مختلفه لتحقيق
الجانب من جانب اخر الذي يدعم ايضا مبادره
الحزام بالطريقه الصينيه فهي تتاقلم ولذلك
تمت المواعظمه بين رؤيه المملكه بدر عذاب
هذا تعاون منه فريد هذا التعامل لا يخلق
التنافس هذا يخلق تعزيز يعني تعزيز
التواصل العالمي للدرجه الاولى وين كانت
يعني معطيات الاساسيه اقتصاديه وتجاريه
لكن هو يفتح نوافذ مختلفه للتواصل فلم في
المملكه وتوائم مبادره الحزام الصينيه مع
رؤيه المملكه اذا بالثانيه تعاون ونحمل
سويا على تحقيق الاهداف المشتركه بمحمد
صلاح يشرك معي ايضا نصيحه في الصين نادر
وونجو الذي يلتحق بنا من العاصمه الصينيه
بكين سيد نادر مرحبا بك معي في هذه
التغطيه ما هي اولويات الرئيس الصيني شيجن
في هذه المباحثات الرسميه الثنائيه ايضا
التي
يعقدها مع الجانب السعودي مع العهد
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز واولي
عهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
مرحبا بكم
من الصين لهذه القمم فالرئيس الصيني
العربي
والارتقائي في مستوى الشراكه في شتى
المجالات بين الصين والسعوديه العربيه
[موسيقى]
وكذلك في مجالات
التكنولوجيا العاليه مثل همم
الاتصالات واا كذلك
في التعزيز الثقه همم السياسيه المتبادله
وتعمل متبادل في مواقف السياسيه في محل
دوليه
بسالك ذلك سيد نادر عن هذه الزياره هي
الزياره الخارجيه الاولى التي يقوم بها
الرئيس الصيني بعد انتخابه
لولايه ثالث كيف
انعكست هذه الزياره اصداه هذه الزياره
ايضا في الصين كيف يمكن الحديث عنها على
ماذا تعول ايضا بالصين في هذه الزياره
اه طبعا هذه ال ايضا اريد ان اضيف ان هذه
هي عمليه يعني اكبر عمليه تبماسيه
الجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه اتجاه الدول
العربيه
تعزيز
استراتيجيه شامله بين السنوات
[موسيقى]
العربيه
اولا في مجال التحاقه هناك همم
نعرف ان السعوديه همم يعني همم اكبر ضمان
هو يعني اكبر همم
الرابط بين مبادره الحزام طريقه
هناك همم يعني همم
طيب عبد السيد جاسر في سياق العلاقات
الدوليه اليوم
لماذا دعت السعوديه الى قمم عامه في زياره
تعتبر بانها زياره خاصه للرئيس السيسي
المملكه وهي تسعى للتنميه والاستقرار في
منطقه ترى انه هذه الشركاء الفلين
بالمملكه عبر دوائر الخليج اساسا ثم الدول
العربيه
وهي تعمل في هذا الاساس على تحقيق هذه
العمليه بشكل كامل اذا بالتالي هي ليست
فقط المملكه احنا بنزورها مثلا الرئيس
الصيني لدوله بحجم وتاثير الصين سواء
اقتصاديا وسياسيا لا تريد ان تنقل اي اولا
تجربه مشتركه تعاون اقتصادي مشترك خدمه
الاطراف اللي على الخليجيه والعربيه
بالكامل وتعزيز الموقف العربي بناء كتله
نتحدث اليوم نتصور انه في المستقبل القريب
قد يكون هناك نوع من التكتل الاقتصادي
والسياسي العرب الذي يختم هذه المراحل
الاولى قامت بها المملكه على ثلاث مرات
اليوم هذه المره الثالثه تدعوا الدول
العربيه كامله ودول الخليج لعقد هذه القمه
للمناقشه بالتالي نقل تصورات
متناهيه لا نقل موحده في الضروره لكن
متناغمه وتهدف الى تحت اذا الصين في هذا
الجانب على المستوى الاقتصادي هي مستفيده
لانه الدول العربيه ولم تكن تكترا لان
اقتصاديا بشكل واضح ومحدد ومنور لكن هناك
نقاط العمليه التي يتم العمل عليها
بالتالي ستكون هي بمثابه شريك للصين في
قضايا مختلفه وهذه شراكه همم المتعدده
تخدم الاطراف في المزايا الاستثماريه
باشكال مختلفه في الجانب الاخر نقل الصوت
في القضايا والملفات العربيه الصين دوله
مؤثره لا يمكن يعني تجاهلها انها تلعب
صحيح ان هي من الدول ذات الرتم الهادي في
الجانب السياسي وهي تشترك مع المملكه
العربيه في النزول الى التنميه اولا وليس
الاستقطبات السياسيه يعني بعيد عن هذا
الجانب بالتالي هذا التقارب في التصور في
الرؤيا يدعم الوقوف اذا هي قد تكون عندما
نسال سيدنا جاسر او يعني ننظر الى هذه
العلاقه بصورتها العامه العلاقه السعوديه
الصينيه بوجهها السياسيه والاقتصادي
التجاري وغيره اين تختلف واين تتفق ال-
ال- ال- البلدين همم سواء بما يخدم مصالح
بعضهما البعض او حتى ان اختلفت المصالح
في هذا الجانب نعود مره اخرى لان المملكه
لا تعول على هذا الجانب كثيرا هي لا ترى
هذه الاتفاقات هذه التعاون على مواقف
سياسيه معينه ما لم تكن مواقف غذائيه او
ضديه بشكل حاسوب نعود انه في تناغم كبير
بدرجه اصلا ممكن تلعب دور مهم في هذا
الجانب دخول يعني هذا التوسع الاقتصادي
يدخل الصين كشريك فعله يعني اليوم ستنشا
مركز اقليم للمصانع الصينيه وهذا المركز
الاقليمي لا يخدم المملكه هو يخدم المنطقه
ككل وهو بالتالي يعزز الحضور الاقتصادي
الى الصين هذه الحضور الاقتصادي هو له
متابعات سياسيه
ان تعمل بالتناغم وانا اعتقد ان هناك نوع
واضح من التقارب المتين والوثيق والمميز
في هذا الجانب خصوصا في المساله تهديدات
الايرانيه في العمل على تحقيق دعم
الاستقرار في المنطقه صوت هي يعني احد
اعضاء المجلس الامن التالي ممكن تعزز هذه
في اعاده قوله الموقف الصيني اللي هو جيد
بشكل العام لكن في نقطه او ثلاث مثلا لما
اتصل بايران وبعض المواقف تحتاج الى مزيد
من التقارب والتفاهم في هذا الجانب بما
يحقق الاستقرار ويحقق التنميه المستهدفه
اساسي كل هذا السؤال الى السيد نادر يعني
هناك بعض النقاط
يعني لا نقل النقاط خلافيه لكن لا تتناغم
مع بعضها البعض كما ذكر السيد جاسر جاسر
في همم بعض الملفات منها طبعا الملف همم
الايراني وهو على راس هذه همم الاولويه
الى اي مدى الوجود الصيني اليوم في
السعوديه المباحثات سيحدث همم توافقا ربما
على همم
المحددات والاطارات العامه لموضوع التعامل
مع همم ايران مستقبلا بعد هذه القمه
اه اعتقدوا هناك
مفاهيم مشتركه لدى الصين والسعوديه وهي ال
ان التنميه
هيبتاع مفتاح الاولات ومفتاح لحاله مشاكل
[موسيقى]
يجب ان يكون عبر الحوار وتفاوت
والاستقرار هو في المقام الاول وهمم
كذلك
المنطقه الشرق الاوساط لا يجب ان تكون همم
منافسات جيوس سياسيه بين الدول الكبرى يجب
ان تكون واحه قوته للتنميه والاستحهار
المشتركه فلذلك اعتقد الصيني وهو همم يعني
الدور الوسائط المناسب ل همم التسويه همم
يعني خلافات بين
الايران
الدول الخليجي وكذلك لان
كل الاتصالات الوثيقه مع اكل الاتراك
المختلفه والصين ايضا تدعو الى اي شيء
الحوار بين الدول الخليجرام لحل المشاكل
ولي حفاظ على التنميه وتجنب السرعات
جسر اليوم ساعه الرياضه طلعتنا بمقاله
للرئيس الصيني شيجن بينجو وهي التي تتزامن
مع هذه الزياره وفي الجزء طبعا في جزء من
هذا المقال تحدث عن علاقه الصين بالسعوديه
التاريخيه والعلاقه الان لكنه ذكر يعني
نقطه مهمه اقل نواصل الجهود الارتقاء
بعلاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين
الصين والمملكه الى مستوى اعلى كيف يمكن
فهم هذه العلاقه اليوم كيف يمكن ايضا
التنبؤ بشكلها مستقبليه اذا كان يتحدث على
انها ستصعد الى مستوى اعلى ما هي عليه
اليوم
ما في نقطه طبعا انا في المكان المهمه هو
تحدث كثير عن الروابط القائمه التاريخيه
والثقافيه المستمده التي تتجاوز التحولات
والتبدلات السياسيه
داخليه قائم مستمره رغم ان لم يكن هناك
علاقات في في روح تقارب فهو من هذه
العلاقات
ويعطيه القوه برغم كل الاحوال رغم كل
تبدلات اليوم فعلا العلاقه السعوديه
الصينيه اليوم في احلى مستويات الامير
محمد سبقنا على زياره الصين عن الادراج
اللغه الصينيه في المدارس
طبعا لما يكون هذا يعني عاطفيا او مزاجك
هنا قرار قائم على الاهميه الاقتصاديه
والثقافيه والسياسيه في المستقبل وحتى
السكانيه فبالتالي تعلم اللغه الصينيه مهم
جدا في التواصل في المرحله المقبله اليوم
الرافع نعتقد سياسي الى مستويات
تصل الى الاتحاد والعمل المشترك فقط في في
الاتفاقات الثنائيه وان ما في ملفات اخرى
ملفات اقتصاديه الشراكه في المنتديات
والمجموعات والمنظمات الدوليه الهمشتراك
ايضا في الجانب السياسي سيكون هناك هو
طبعا التقرب وكمان سابقا يعني متين وكامل
لكن سيزداد اعتقد بشكل اكثر قوه اكثر
وضوحا وستم حسين طرفا ضاغطا بشكل ايجابي
بتحقيق الاستقرار والمسام وتحقيق
الاستقرار في هذه المنطقه والاتفاقات
الاقتصاديه والمشاريع الاقتصاديه هي ليست
مشاريع ان يمرحون يعني خطه عمل المستقبليه
تتنامى وتتزايد لنقل وتوطين التقنيه
والصناعات ولا تكون المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مركز السلاسل الامداد لمنطقه
الخليج والمنطقه العربيه بشكل في المرحله
الاولى وايضا بتعزيز التيار الصينيه في
المنافع المشتركه هذه تزيد الروابط بشكل
كبير وتجمعها ويصبح العمل عليها بشكل واضح
الاستقرار والثبات في الدولتين والرؤيه
الواضحه والبعد عن النزاعات السياسيه يدعم
هذه التوجهات ويحقق
يا جدعان ينتقل اخيرا الى السيد نادر
وينجو اختر معك في في هذا المقال ايضا همم
الرئيس الصيني وصف همم السعوديه همم قال
في ثنايا هذا المقال نحن فخورونا
بالانجازات التي حققها صديقنا الحميد
واسال هنا عن هذا المصطلح عن هذه الشراكه
عندما يصف الرئيس الصيني السعوديه بانها
صديق حميم
للصين فيها كذا مرحله كيف يمكن ان نفهم
هذا التعبير ان نفهم هذا الجزء من هذا
المقال المهم الذي كتبه الرئيس اليوم في
صحيفه الرياضه
[موسيقى]
مع السعوديه مهمه جدا
وتطور شهاده التطورات السريعه في سنوات
الاخيره وخاصه بعد همم
عن 2016
التنميه في السعوديه والصين ترى انه يعني
همم
همم المواقف او متاحم تنميه المتشابهه مع
الصين فهمم يعني الرؤيه همم
الثلاثين مثل ما كان همم اثرت مثل سياسه
الاسلام
[موسيقى]
تدخل مسار تطور سريع يعني يمكن ان همم
تحقيقه همم السعوديه كان ذلك في همم السن
في ذلك لان همم تعاون سياتي يمكن تقديم
المساعدات او خبرات كثيره في هذا المجال
في همم
[موسيقى]
هدهود الانتاج المحليه السعوديه وهمم يعني
عمليه تصنيع في قطاعات الصناعيه كثيره ان
همم تساعد السعوديه ان تصبح همم
ايضا تتفق مع الاستراتيجيات في السعوديه
شكر ضيفي الكاتب الصحفي من العاصمه
الصينيه بكين شكرا ايضا لضيفي هنا في
الاستديو الاستاذ جاسر الجاسر الكاتب
الصحفي السعودي انتهت نافذتنا من هنا
مستمرون معكم طبعا في ااا تغطياتنا
المستمره الحيه المباشره من هنا من استديو
العربيه في المركز الاعلامي المصاحب لقمم
الرياض بانتظار طبعا قمه سعوديه صينيه هذا
اليوم مباحثات رسميه ستجري على اعلى مستوى
بين البلدين بين العهد السعودي الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان مع الرئيس الصيني شيجن همم
بينج اعود مره اخرى الى استديوهات هنا في
العاصمه الرياض والى زميله فاطمه
[موسيقى]
تشهد مدارس السعوديه اقبال واسعا مشاهدينا
من الطلاب على تعلم اللغه الصينيه تركي
المشاري واحد من الطلاب الذي فهموا
اساسيات هذه اللغه الجديده عليه بعد ان
اختار تعلمها
بعد اكثر من عامين على بدء تدريسها للطلاب
اختياريا تزداد اعداد الطلاب الراغبين في
تعلم اللغه الصينيه علهم يستخدمونها سواء
خلال زياراتهم للصين او للدراسه فيها
مستقبلا
يوجد اقبال متزايد من طلاب المرحله
الثانويه على تعلم اللغه الصينيه في
المقرر الاختياري الذي يتم ادراجه لهم ضمن
المنهج هناك ايضا اهميه كبيره لتدريس
اللغه الصينيه بالنسبه للطلاب والطالبات
الطلاب والطالبات يقوم بتعلم لغه جديده في
سن مبكر هذا بالتاكيد له اثر كبير على
تعزيز
وتنميه مهارات التواصل هناك ايضا فرصه لهم
للاطلاع على ثقافه اخرى طبعا احنا في
اللغه الصينيه او طريقه تدريسها في
المدارس هي ماده اختياريه او ماده حره
يسجل فيها الطالب عندما يكون عندها الرغبه
او الشغف للتعلم مثل ما انت عارف هي لغه
جديده رموز جديده
طالب يحب يتعلم كيف هذه الرموز كيف
الكلمات كيف راح يتكلم باللغه الصينيه
خمسه اسابيع كانت كفيله بتعلم تركي
المشاري الطالب في المرحله الثانويه
اساسيات اللغه الصينيه التي اختار دراستها
للتعرف اكثر على ثقافات الصينيين ويبدو
انه يبلي حسنا فقد نجح بفهم اساسيات اللغه
خلال فتره وجيزه
اول شيء نبدا باول جمله
مشاري انا عارف باسمي واسمي تركي خالد
المشاري ممتاز الثانيه
وهذا عمري 18 سنه والجمله الثالثه
يعني انا اكون طالب العلاقات السعوديه مع
الصين تتقدم يوما بعد يوم ومثل ادراج
اللغه الصينيه في المناهج الدراسيه بالم
خطوه مهمه تجاه تعزيز هذه العلاقه باعتبار
ان تعلم اللغه الصينيه يعد جسرا يزيد
الروابط السياحيه والثقافيه بين شعبي
السعوديه والصين من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه
ضمن مئه امراه مؤثره في العالم خلال العام
الحالي
اهلا بكم من جديد مع تصاعد الاضطرابات
والاحتجاجات سلطات النظام الايراني تنفذ
اول عمليه اعدام ضد متظاهر ادانته باصابه
حارس امن بسكين طويل واغلاق احد شوارع
طهران وذلك وفقه وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه
شبه الرسميه واضافت الوكاله وان المحكمه
العليا رفضت الاستئناف الذي قدمه المتهم
مبررات الحكم بالقول ان افعاله تمثل جريمه
الحرابه
ومن ومن تصعيد النظام الايراني ضد
الاحتجاجات الى المخاوف الدوليه حيث دعت
منظمه العفو الدوليه السلطات الايرانيه
والمرشده الايراني الى الغاء حكم الاعدام
بحق الطبيب حميد قر حسن له على خلفيه
مشاركته في الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في البلاد
واكد انه تعرض للتعذيب خلال اعتقاله كما
جددت المنظمه دعوتها الى ضروره الافراج عن
الهام افكاري وشقيقها وحيد وهما شقيقه
نويد افكاري المصارعه الايرانيه المعدوم
وادانه اعتقالهما التعسفي
وافقت لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي على قرار من الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي لدعم الاحتجاجات ضد
النظام الايراني وفي السياق اكدت السنتر
الجمهوريه مارشا بلاك بيرد على ضروره دعم
الولايات المتحده للمتظاهرين حتى يضمن
ووصفته بالنصر كما وصفت بلاك بيرن الغاء
النظام الايراني شرطه الاخلاق بالواجهه
للالهاء عما يريده المحتجون الايرانيون
الراغبون في تحرير بلدهم من القمع من
جهتها اكدت السيناتور الديمقراطيه جاكي
الروزن انها ستواصل العمل مع زملائها في
الكونجرس لدعم الشعب الايراني ومحاسبه
النظام على انتهاكاته لحقوق الانسان
واعمال الجامعه
[موسيقى]
من سنين
احمد الياسري سيد احمد هل فشل النظام
الايراني في التهدئه هو ما دفعه اللجوء
لاعدام المتظاهرين
حضرتك استاذه فاطمه من جميع مشاهدين
قناتكم الكريمه
او التخندق بمربع الحلول الامنيه او الذي
يجعل ظاهره الاحتجاجات قبل ايراني
على سرير مطعم الايراني امريكي
تتحدث عن فكره احترامهم بالحوار
يعني انا اخذنا هذا النموذج انا اعتقد انه
فكره الاحتراق
يعني لم تعد مجديه باستخدام همم
يعني مقابله الدعوات
التي توجد
استمرار همم
وهي التي تجعل عمليه الاحتجاج ممتعه
فقدان الثقه بين النظام والشعب الايراني
كذلك سيد احمد يعني همم لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في امريكا همم وافقت على دعم
الاحتجاجات في ايران كيف تقرا هذا الدعم
وهذه الخطوه
الجديده الحقيقيه
2019 الحركه الخضراء اول 2019
دجاجات العمال الفلاح
الى الاجتماع
نساء
الايرانيات على التايمز لا يوجد اسم محسن
امين وهي تعتبر يعني ربما الايقونه لهذه
الاحتجاجات الحاصله الان
بغض النظر ان وجدان لم يوجد
المراه في ايران تحولت الى موضوع توديه
مواقع التواصل الفنانين في العام المفكرون
كلهم حصل عمليه التجارب مع هذه القضيه
وهذا يشكل بعض انا تابعث على فاطمه
الايرانيه وجود التصريح يعني
يتحدث عن الماده 99 مهند رامي التي ترجع
كل تصرفات الدوله
كيف يعني يتم اصطدام الشعب الذي هو من
المفترض هو بحسن الدستور الايراني هو
المصدر الحقيقي لملح السلطه الشرعيه شرعيه
المجتمعيه يتحدث عنها ولذلك همم
وصلت الى مرحله القياده وهذا ما نريد ان
يشير له في العديد من المقابلات التي
سعيد التعامل مع المحتجين سيد احمد وايضا
على تعاملهم مع انفسهم يعني تاره ثانيه
يشدون على المحتجين ويقمعونه وتره اخرى
نرى تقارير تتحدث عن استعدادهم للخروج من
ايران واللجوء الى دول حليفه ما الذي يحدث
برايك في الداخل الايراني من ناحيه النظام
رئيس الحقيقه
وحصول الاتجاهات
التي تقوم باسرائيل وبعض الدول
يعني همم
شكرا لك من سيدني الباحث في الشان
الايراني احمد الياسري
[تصفيق]
تضمنت قائمه مجله الامريكيه لاكثر 100
امراه ملهمه في العالم تضمنت 9 ايرانيات
من بينهم الناشطات الايرانيات جوهر عشقي
نرجس محمد
قليان ونزين زغري راتكليف هذا ولم تشمل
هذه القائمه الفتاه الكرديه مهس اميني
التي اندلعت الاحتجاجات بسبب قتل النظام
الايراني لها باحد مراكز الشرطه
[موسيقى]
افادت مصادر للعربيه بان شركه طيران معراج
الايرانيه المرتبطه بالحرس الثوري
الايراني بدات في تسيير رحلات الى مطار
بيروت لاول مره وبصوره غير اعتياديه وذكرت
المصادر اولى رحلات شركه معراج الايرانيه
وصلت الى مطار بيروت في الرابعه عشر من
نوفمبر الماضي وسط المخاوفه من ان يتم
استغلالها في نقل اسلحه ومعدات حساسه الى
حزب الله واضافت المصادر
الايرانيه تهبط بشكل اسبوعي في مطار دمشق
الدولي الذي تعرض لقصف الاسرائيلي بسبب
نقل شحنات اسلحه ايرانيه وقالت المصادر
ايضا ان اسرائيل
تهريب الاسلحه الايرانيه الى لبنان مباشره
الى ان هذه الخطوه ستلحق اضرار بالغه
بالاقتصاد اللبناني الذي يعاني بالفعل
التهابات الولايات المتحده الرئيس الروسي
في فلاديمير بوتن بعدم المسؤوليه بعد
تصريحاته عن مخاطر اللجوء الى الاسلحه
النوويه في النزاع في اوكرانيا وقال
المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارج
ان اي استخفاف في الحديث عن الاسلحه
النوويه امر غير مسؤول على الاطلاق من
جانبه يعتبر المستشار الالماني
في حربها على اوكرانيا قائل لان المجتمع
الدولي رسم خطا احمر لروسيا على هذا
الصعيد وعزل المستشار الالماني هذا
التراجع الى واقع ان المجتمع الدولي ومن
ضمنها الصين رسم خطا احمر لموسكو بشان
تهديدها هذا وكان الرئيس الروسي العظيم
اقر بان الحرب ستكون طويله الابد محذرا من
خطرا اندلاع حرب النوويه واشار الى انه
رغم النزاع الطويل لكنه حقق نتائجها مهمه
بالنسبه لموسكو حيث ان 150,000 جندي من
الاحتياط التحقوا بالفعل بما يدين القتال
في اوكرانيا وذلك مشاه والنبي حسب الرئيس
الروسي الذي اكد انه لا حاجه لعمليه تعبئه
العسكريه جديده في الوقت الراهن في
المقابل اتهمت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسل فوندر لاين روسيا بتعمد استهداف
المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه المدنيه في
اوكرانيا فاندر لاين جددت في الوقت ذاته
وقوف المفوضيه الاوروبيه الى جانب
اوكرانيا كما اعلنت عن حزمه تاسعه من
العقوبات
عند
السيسي السيسي
قمه سعوديه صينيه في الرياض للدفع
بالشراكه الاقتصاديه بين الجانبين الى
مرحله جديده
وسط محاولات قمع الاحتجاجات السلطات
الايرانيه تنفذ اول عقوبه اعدام ضد
محتجالطانه رجل امن
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي توافق على قرار لدعم الاحتجاجات
الايرانيه
بوتين يحذر من مخاطر اللجوء للسلاح النووي
في اوكرانيا وواسطه تتهمه بعدم المسؤوليه
احييكم من جديد وجهها وزير الداخليه
العراقي باستبدال قائدي شرطه محافظه ذي
قار على خلفيه الاحتجاجات التي شهدتها
المحافظه وسقوط ضحايا ومصابين وبحسب بيان
الداخليه تم تعيين العميد مكي شناع قائدا
للشرطه في المحافظه فيما اعلنت قياده
العمليات المشتركه في العراق حاله التاهب
القصوى لقوه مكافحه الشغب والشرطه في
العاصمه بغداد وفي هذا الاطار مشاهدينا
نشرت القياده مئات العناصر مع تعزيز الجهد
الامني بالقرب من الاهداف الحيويه المهمه
في العاصمه العراقيه افادت مصادر صحفيه او
فلسطينييه ان قوه الجيش الاسرائيليه قتلت
ثلاثه فلسطينيين واصابت عددا اخرا بجروح
وذلك خلال اقتحامها مدينه ومخيم جنين شمال
الضفه الغربيه حيث اندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه
مع مقاتلين فلسطينيين حاولوا التصدي
للقوات المقتحمه
في كابول لا يبدو ان حمى متابعه كاس
العالم تنتشر في المدينه كحالي اغلب المدن
العالم وذلك بسبب المتعه المفقوده جراء
الظروف المعيشيه الصعبه في وقت يعيش معظم
الشعب الافغاني في مناطقنائيه حيث لا
كهرباء تمكنهم من مشاهده
الى اهمال الحكومه للمناشط الرياضيه
الزميل عبد الله نادر تابعث امام الشباب
الافغاني بكاس العالم نتابع معه التفاصيل
في هذا الفندق وسط مدينه كابول العاصمه
يشاهد عدد القليل من الشباب الافغاني كاس
العالم يقول معظمهم ان الظروف الاقتصاديه
الصعبه في البلاد والضغوطات النفسيه لا
تترك لهم فرصه التمتع بما يدور في كاس
العالم اما صاحب الفندق فيلقي باللائمه
على السلطات الافغانيه لعدم رغبه الشباب
في مشاهده الرياضه
بالاهتمام بالرياضه وخاصه كره القدم
جامعي من المهتمين بالرياضه يحضر يوميا
الى هذا الفندق ليشاهد كاس العالم يضيف ان
بعضا من الشباب الافغان مثله مولعون بكره
القدم ولكل منهم منتخببه المفضل همم
شباب الافغاني يشاهدون كره القدم في كاس
العالم التي تدور في قطر وانا شخصيا
اشاهدها كل يوم وانا من محبي منتخب
الارجنتين هنا وفي هذا الملعب وتزامنا مع
كاس العالم تلعب فرق افغانيه مختلفه والتي
توجهت الى كابول من جميع المقاطعات التي
يبلغ عددها 34 مقاطعه
يشاهد بطوله كاس العالم نعم بعض من لا
يشاهدها في المنازل والفنادق واخرون
يشاهدونها في المكاتب والمحلات التجاريه
تعرض العاب كاس العالم في قطر في اماكن
خاصه مثل الفنادق والمقاهي وليست في اماكن
عامه يسهل عليها التردد لكل من اراد
مشاهدتها كاس العالم يبدا فيما لا تمتلك
افغانستان منتخبا وطنيا بعد سيطره طالبان
حيث تم اخراج اعضاء المنتخب الوطني
بمساعده الفيفا بعد وصول طالبان للسلطان
عبد الله نادر العربيه كابول
في طريقه الى البيت الابيض يواجه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب عثرات عده قد تغلق
تلقت تلك الطرق في وجهه
طريق وعره يسلكها الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب للعوده الى البيت الابيض
متعثرا بالعديد من الحجاره التي تقف في
طريقه ولا ربما يصل لنهايه مسدوده لم تمر
ثلاثه اسابيع على حمله ترامب الرئاسيه
لعام 2024
لتنهال عليه المشاكل تباعا
[تصفيق]
رغم ان ترامب الوحيد الذي اعلن ترشحه عن
الحزب الجمهوري للرئاسه الا ان احتمالات
اعلان الترشح رمدي سانتوس حكيم فلوريدا
تثير القلق بالنسبه للرئيس السابق خاصه ان
الاستطلاعات الراي فضل الديسانتس الذي لم
يترشح بعد على ترامب
[تصفيق]
اكبر الاسماك في مسيره ترامب السياسيه
مبنى كابتل لجنه التحقيق في احداث السادس
من يناير ستحل التوصيات الجنائيه الى
وزاره العدل ليصدر القرار المؤثر في
المستقبل ترامب السياسي
بعد الاستيلاء على الوثائق التي وجدت في
منزل ترامب اسقطت محكمه الاستئناف جهود
فريقه لتعيين خبرا خاص لمراجعتها كما ان
المحكمه العليا رفضت محاولات ترامب لمنع
لجنه مجلس النواب من الحصول على سجلاته
الضريبيه
[تصفيق]
هيئه محلفين في نيويورك ادانت منظمه ترامب
بالاحتلال والتهرب الضريبي قائله الى
المنظمه عملت على مدار 15 عاما لتنفيذ
المخطط التهرب ورغم ان الملياردير لم توجه
له اي تهمه الى ان المناظمه توجه غرامات
بقيمه مليون و600 الف دولار اما الاسوء
فهو النكسه المحتمله في طريق عودته للبيت
الابيض نتيجه التلوث سمعه المنظمه الى عمر
العربيه
نشير مشاهدينا الى ان الرئيس الصيني
شيجيبين بالفعل وصل قبل قليل الى قصر
اليمامه في الرياض لعقد قمه مع الملك
سلمان وفي عوده الى سياق نشرتنا تنظر
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه في قضيه من
شانها احداث تحول جوهري في طريقه عمل
الديمقراطيه في ما يتعلق بانتخابات
الكونغرس والبيت الابيض
في امريكا لتظهر بعضها عده اشكاليه اخرها
امام المحكمه العليا
اثار ملف قانون الانتخابي مخاوف الشديده
لدى اليسار وتيارات اخرى كونه قد يحدث
ثوره في تنظيم انتخابات الرئاسه
الاستماع امام المحكمه العليا الامريكيه
على نظريه القانونيه جديده اقترحها اعضاء
الكونجرس
ويبث فيها يونيو القادمه
فيما يعهد الدستور حاليا الى مشرعي كل
ولايه بمهمه تحديد وقت ومكان واجراءات
الاقتراع ما سمح لهم باتخاذ القرارات بشان
التصويت بالبريد والساعات عمل مكاتب
الاقتراع والوثائق التي يجب تقديمها
للتسجيل في القوائم الانتخابيه مع ذلك
تخضع قوانينهم للمراجعه من قبل المحاكم
المحليه وقد يستخدم حاكم الولايه حق النقض
هذا ما يريد النواب المنتخب
المحليين على حرمان بعض الناخبين من حق
التصويت وتقسيم الدوائر الانتخابيه كما
يرون ذلك مناسبا ومن المحتمل ان يؤدي الى
تخريب نتيجه الانتخابات
الديمقراطيون يرون في نظريه مشرعي
الولايات المستقله محاوله جمهوريه للتلاعب
بالعمليه الانتخابيه للتحقيق مكاسب
السياسيه امام المحافظين فيرون ان النظام
السياسي سيعاني بشكل كبير اذا ترك تحديد
الدوائر الانتخابيه خارج نطاق السيطره
الهنديه لطفل عمره ثمان سنوات سقط في بئر
ضيقه بعمق 121 مترا في احدى المناطق
النائيه على غرار ماساه الطفل ريان في
المغرب
[موسيقى]
نهايه النشره نختم بالعناوين
قمه سعوديه صينيه في الرياض للدفع بشراكه
الاقتصاديه بين الجانبين الى مرحله جديده
وسط محاولات قم على احتجاجات السلطات
الايرانيه تنفذ اول عقوبه اعدام ضد محتجا
لطعنه رجل امن
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي توافقوا على قرار لدعم
الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
وبوتين يحذر من مخاطر اللجوء للسلاح
النووي في اوكرانيا و واشنطن بدورها تتهمه
بعدم المسؤوليه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]